let me ask you about what's going on in
these schools so we saw this in Virginia
there uh Ian's actually got one of these
books these are these are books that are
rated this one right here genderqueers
gender queer I don't know if you guys
have seen we've had that in my testimony
uh two days ago in the senate in
Harrisburg 18 and up on Amazon
but these books are in grade school
libraries and when parents simply say
hey this material is not appropriate for
my kid they get kicked out of these
meetings they get told not to speak they
get they get the boot and then we're
told just that this is the kind of stuff
that grade school kids should have
access to so was there something that
happened recently with you guys or you
know just tell me what your thoughts are
yeah we had a hearing in Harrisburg and
brought in uh several testifiers several
moms from the Southeastern part of the
state and uh one of the moms had a stack
about 10 different books and she read
from one of them which was completely
disgusting it's it's it's it's it's it
repugnant it's that bad do you remember
which book specifically this one was
I don't she read it it was so bad that
the committee chair said okay we
understand now
um but the pictures in some of those
books that she had there are extremely
graphic and it's for elementary ed kids
um and if you and I share that materials
with with the underage people that that
would be an offense we'd be arrested
that's right that disgusting Josh
Shapiro my opponent supports that being
in the libraries we actually had a bill
that would protect kids from obscene
material in the schools age-appropriate
books and it was called book Banning by
the Democrats and our Democrat Governor
wolf vetoed it and my opponent cheered
on the same side here they celebrate of
course gender pronoun games in our
schools our schools are becoming really
a culture War class in Pennsylvania
because they know if they can
indoctrinate the kids they get votes in
you know in 18 years kids are told not
to tell their parents if they're
transitioning or which pronouns they're
using and the parents will get on board
later on Levine is part of this dot the
great Dr Levine our secretary of Health
in Pennsylvania now the second most
powerful Health official in the nation
here and Admiral now a woman of the year
you can't make this stuff up many people
talk about defending women's rights but
they can't even Define what a woman is
now I mean it's just insane yeah Matt
Walsh is doing I think he's doing a
screening tour I know he's got a big
rally in Tennessee
um but yeah you've seen Matt Walsh's
documentary what is a woman yep I mean
that's that's it right there look
um I'm I'm all for uh making sure people
are living happy happy and healthy lives
for for the trans Community but we're
talking about now is it's a simple issue
parents saying hey me personally I don't
think it is right for my children to
read a book that shows graphic sexual
depictions and they're being called book
burners fascists transphobes domestic
terrorists if you talk too loud in the
school board meeting something's really
weird about that yeah there is I I you
know what I would just say you can ask
well if you ever get the chance because
he's not gonna debate you you need to
ask him do you think Talent like you
think uh Banning Playboy would be book
Bannings is that a Banning Banning a
book to ban Hustler from schools we're
not talking about telling kids they
can't read ideas it's specifically that
these are adult adult oriented things
you know it's one thing if you're like
and actually actually I brought this up
with uh I can't remember who I brought
it up with um
we have a lot of guests the Bible has
certain depictions in it that are
actually adult and graphic and my
attitude is yeah the parents should be
there talking with their kids and
deciding if they want their kids to be
reading certain things I don't care
where it is I don't care if it's a
religious text or if it's a book the
idea that teachers will decide for the
parents and the parents have no say
somehow equates to book Bannings is is
ludicrous yeah and we we see the videos
on lives of tick tock you know and
they're using their platform to
indoctrine me and and that's that's an
abuse of power there you're there to
educate not to indoctrinate we want to
teach kids you know how to think not
what to think and that's that's a
dangerous Trend here and now that
there's a push to to force the parents
out of their their kids lives in their
education in their choices and what have
you in their understanding in their
world view that that's troubling you
know we started off this conversation
about
you know Lieutenant mastriana serving on
the Iron Curtain you know defending
against that that the Godless system
that Ronald Reagan described
and in those days they're in a Soviet
Empire of course schools were used to
indoctrinate to socialize and
indoctrinate according to the edicts of
the rulers and uh that's and I remember
being I'm so glad it's not like that in
America but we're seeing that coming
here in America are you familiar with
ESG I am so that's uh I I view that as
like the Chinese Communist party but for
the the you know the Western version yes
they've got the Chinese Communist party
has an office and all their major
companies so that they have political
control within how with how these
companies operate ESG is basically the
same thing it's a workaround to get
ideology into the business you know what
though I think it's not working
I think we're seeing the backlash there
are many states I think West Virginia
cut ties with uh businesses based on ESG
what was the story you want to pull that
one up yeah I think we talked about it
recently they said that they wouldn't do
business with a specific company based
on their idea uh penalizes major
companies for embracing ESG West
Virginia did that there you go about
four months ago do does the governor
have the authority would you be
interested in this yes yes I do and we
do need to elect a republican General
Assembly that's just a constitutional
Factor but to me together with the
Republican General Assembly we can cut
off ties with businesses or not invest
in China Russia or companies that work
against our ideas and ideals I wonder if
that same goes for free speech
supporting the First Amendment and
social media companies that take control
of the commons since I've been on the
receiving end you know much as you guys
have been on some of the censorship here
which is just repugnant to me you know
who's deciding what right and wrong is
on some of these issues we've debated
over the past couple years which you
won't bring up because we're going to be
banned on some of the platforms
ironically but I have introduced
legislation I would make it out these
these social media platforms culpable
and subject to being sued by citizens in
Pennsylvania if that passes obviously
I'll sign into law and that they they
cannot screen speech that they just
don't simply like that's exactly what
they do I get my thoughts are that we
need to force these companies to free
their software code so that other
developers can pick up like a copy of
Twitter and launch their own Twitter
that they then interoperate because if
you start telling private companies what
they have to do it feels like bashes
like it's like I don't want the
government
but but if people don't like Twitter's
terms of service because they're getting
banned they go to the other Twitter and
then they can still view you you've
swayed me halfway in excellent I don't
agree with this idea of so here's here's
how I view it you free the software code
basically you make the code for the
program available to everybody to make
their own I don't like that it's kind of
like if you build something then
someone's allowed to take copy off your
work and that's like an IP and copyright
thing however I still think freeing the
code is something we probably have to do
because of the algorithms yeah because
we don't know how Facebook is
experimenting on us and we know they do
so this was a big story Facebook
actually was experimenting on people
they were purposefully sending happy
content and hurtful content to people to
see how they would react and sure enough
when they flooded someone's fee with the
pressing content they became depressed
that is psychotic well they were
launching psychological experiments on
unsuspecting users who didn't know that
they were participating in a program
that manipulated the algorithm to see
how they can manipulate their emotions
so that's some larger psychological
warfare that's happening that of course
they're they're seeing what they could
get away with they're seeing how far
they could manipulate a human being if
you can make someone feel sad you can
make someone believe a particular idea
that's god-like power and authority that
I think should be absolutely put in
check and I I kind of agree with Tim
more than I do with Ian him with Ian
because we need to understand what's
happening behind the scenes what is in
the algorithm who's being promoted who's
being demoted who's getting a fair share
of viewership whose ideas are being
shared which ideas are being censored
and more importantly make the code of
conduct simple and enforceable don't
make it vague don't make it General
don't punish people don't delete their
livelihood don't take them away from the
market of of ideas just because they
expressed an idea and you're going to
use an overall vague term in order to
destroy their ability to communicate
that is Draconian that is evil and a lot
of these companies have ties to
governments ties to intelligence
agencies especially with their start so
how do you tackle that as a governor
that's that's a hard question yeah and
there's not an easy solution is that you
know Ian I mean it's a tough one know we
want to protect Free Speech clearly and
we want to have a free exchange of ideas
and we've been clamped down in so many
areas you know we can not even mention
all the topics people know what they are
but at what point you know when they
start threatening violence what have you
as we see as we've seen before you know
who who determines where the line is I
mean it was so much easier when we were
growing up I mean free speech if if he
said something to someone that they
didn't like they you duke it out you
just punch each other you know then it's
resolved on the spot for instance Ethan
Klein just got banned off YouTube uh
seven day ban or something for saying
that he thought Ben shapir should be
what gassed I think well if there was he
said if they if there is another kind of
Holocaust that that's the first one and
it was a joke but it was a very poorly
veiled joke and it was sort of like not
a direct call to violence it's not
illegal because it's not um you know
what do they call it when it's like you
need a time and a place you say it
should happen on this time it's in this
place that's illegal that's imminent it
wasn't an imminent threat but these
these veiled threats are enough for
social media company these a lot of
times in their terms to be like that's
not allowed here I don't agree I think
it's it's First Amendment protected
speech it is violent it can incite
violence though so that's a problem well
look look I wanna I wanna just address
this one just a little bit we didn't get
into it but I don't think Ethan Klein
should have been suspended uh I even
said it the other day when we went over
the comments in the first place but the
fact that he's trying to claim it's a
joke it's like dude you should have said
it was a joke after he said it right in
the same way man if you're gonna do a
joke like that he said at first he said
it was a joke before he was even allowed
to say it before his team like
immediately kind of shut him down so
yeah right but my point is like when you
when you hate someone and insult them
and rag on them No One's Gonna accept it
as a joke right it's just not like if I
came out and said something like that
about AOC no I'm just kidding man come
on dude we're heavily critical of her I
called her a con artist and a grifter
repeatedly today I wish her nothing but
happiness and a long life because I
don't want I don't want I don't want
pain suffering and violence so I'm not
gonna even joke about it but who would
accept it anyway what was it there used
to be like FCC regulations that you
couldn't go on ABC News and say
something like that yes and now the FCC
doesn't with it what's that I think I
think a lot of the the restrictions on
the media have been lifted have been
like rules have been changed that's
allowing a lot more of this garbage so
we had a FCC would would say like yeah
it's legal but it's not allowed on the
network but now there's no it's not
allowed on the network talking it's up
to these private First Amendment
companies instead of the FCC it's it's
definitely illegal it's legal to do it
but but whether or not it's righteous I
don't know or or Justified or any of
that
I I air on the side of free speech
personally I but you know if you say
well someone rid me of this priest you
know that's and then the priest gets
killed yeah like yeah I don't think you
should I don't think that should be
banned I don't think what Ethan Klein
said should get him banned I think we
should all get to hear it and then be
like wow that was gross you know but if
he if he thinks it's a joke and he
thinks it's funny that's fine I kind of
think that
you know look people are allowed to tell
jokes I'm not gonna I'm not gonna get a
comedian fired because he said he's had
jokes I don't like I'm just gonna be
like oh watch something else that's
that's the thing I think I don't think
they understand right now Ethan's you
know attacking or being very critical of
Ben Shapiro because Ben said if another
Holocaust happens I hope Ethan and his
family Escape but that's just me and
then he's like you know these fascists
they don't get it blah blah blah and I'm
like dude
when the people on the left say that we
should ban comedians censor people and
shut them down that's extremism that's
authoritarianism yeah I don't think
y'all should be banned because it's
simple I'm an adult and I'll be like
I'll watch something else
he's a comedian he's not funny because
he says mean things about me it's like
okay I'll just watch something else I
co-founded mines The Social Network
minds and uh it's basically First
Amendment it's it's whatever's legal in
Connecticut is legal on the site you
have weird rules like spam which don't
exist in the in the Constitution that
you've got to kind of make but I yeah
there's there's interesting things
um doxing for instance yes that's First
Amendment protected but I don't think it
should be allowed yeah I agree but that
that's a challenge though then right
because if you want to uphold the First
Amendment people are allowed to hold up
your address on a on a placard I mean
the White Pages used to do it now we try
to keep it a little bit more private so
what do you do
but I just think I I think it's there's
one rule I'm like yeah doxing you know
we can ban that yeah all right
definitely on a slippery slope here you
know and it's happened so quickly to us
since 2020. this is why I like the idea
of freeing the code because I want to
leave the decision up to the uh Network
creators of if they want to ban doxing
on their Network or not right we just
gotta find where free the code doesn't
mean like give out your IP and all the
information all the you know the
intellectual property you've actually
done in writing that code there has to
be a line where it depends on what kind
of business you are I think I think it
depends on what kind of you know we've
talked about this too with um with like
whether Twitter's a platform whether
it's a it's publishing this information
I don't know it has to be discussed as
we worked out because that should it
should be a platform it should be like a
phone company and the the tweets should
be on me not have nothing to do with
Twitter right that's why we need to do I
hope when Elon buys this I hope he just
decentralizes the whole thing and just
as like I no longer have the ability to
ban anybody bye have a nice day
that'd be fantastic yeah he'd definitely
make Twitter great again
well I think one of the challenges to be
realistic is you know people can create
fake accounts and then spam the platform
with garbage so and they can do illegal
stuff too well then that's that's that's
the cops problem but if if you're a
network owner and someone puts something
illegal up and you don't immediately
remove it you're complicit in
decentralizes it like I said if Elon
removes his ability by putting Twitter
out as a decentralized system and he and
he just has Twitter no longer has the
ability to ban accounts like it's hosted
on other servers and people can host
their own servers he like federates it
or something yeah then it's that person
yeah yeah right and the police can go to
you yeah I mean look dude if you go out
in the street and stand if you go if you
go into a hotel and start screaming
racist things they're not going to come
and shut down the hotel
yeah like oh the hotel is hosting this
this offensive speech let's say you say
you you go in there and cite violence
not going to go in the hotel and be like
well you know it was in your space so
you're in trouble no they're gonna
arrest you yeah so that that's the way
it should be if you go onto Twitter and
you say this stuff Twitter should be
like help police yeah there's a guy on
our platform doing saying inciting
violence and committing crime that's how
mines does it right now there you go
yeah man simple as that good thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there